deuxième semaine de vaccination au liban
est déjà une première polémique
seize députés se sont fait vacciner dans
l'enceinte du parlement ce mardi
problème ils sont accusés de ne pas
s'être enregistrés sur la plateforme en
ligne condition obligatoire pour avoir
accès au vaccin
ce qu'il s'est passé et inexcusables et
inacceptables
cela n'aurait jamais dû arriver et cela
ne doit pas se reproduire
même si je ne dis pas que cela ne se
reproduira pas ce qui est arrivé n'a
rien à voir avec le directeur de tels ou
tels centres de vaccination qui appelle
deux personnes et les laisse entrer
c'est une erreur qui est symbolique le
parlement est censé représenter le
peuple libanais la banque mondiale
principal bailleur de fonds du liban à
verser 34 millions de dollars à beyrouth
pour soutenir sa lutte contre le kobe 19
face à la polémique elle menace
désormais de suspendre ses aides
les modalités de ces vaccinations ne
respecte pas le plan national décidé en
accord avec la banque mondiale
nous enregistrerons les violations des
conditions de vaccination établi sur
lesquels nous nous étions mis d'accord
afin d'assurer une vaccination juste et
équitable
si ces violations sont confirmées la
banque mondiale peut suspendre le
financement des vaccins et son soutien
au liban dans la lutte contre le coc vie
de 19
j'en appelle à la responsabilité de
chacun indépendamment de votre poste
inscrivez vous et attendez votre tour
une vague d'indignation déferle depuis
sur les réseaux sociaux
le hashtag non wasta non au népotisme
est en tête des tendances sur twitter
cette affaire ajoute un peu plus à la
défiance d'une partie des libanais
envers leur classe politique dans un
pays rongé par la corruption
la première phase de vaccination est
censé être réservée au personnel médical
et aux personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans
inscrits sur la plateforme internet
pourtant un rapport de la croix rouge
libanaise la firme depuis le lancement
de la campagne 40% des centres de
vaccination ne respecterait pas les
mesures prévues et des groupes non
prioritaires ou des personnes non
inscrites ont été vaccinées au total dix
sept mille personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées au liban le pays de six
millions d'habitants recense 350 mille
cas de kovy 19 dont plus de 4000 décès